feminism has taken over the church and
your belief about like men taking these
born-again virgins and how the church is
like more prescribed towards women oh
because they always argue the female
point of view it's like I can't even
have a conversation with the Christians
recently and it's hard because I'm a
Catholic okay I was you know 12 years of
Catholic school I would consider myself
Catholic I'm not I'm not a die-hard
right but you know and it's unfortunate
because when I was having that
conversation I was talking about earlier
with the cheating the Christian's first
response was well they can divorce like
it says in the Bible they can divorce
and I'm like we should be on the same
team yeah we should believe the family
should stay together but you guys
immediately take the woman's side and
you guys never talk about these women
that don't sleep with their husbands
yeah and I've talked to so many divorce
attorneys that tell me this that I know
this is a problem and I never hear you
guys preach about I've never heard you
preach about submission
you guys say you should submit to each
other what the hell does that mean like
genuinely and and this is when a Rolo I
watched his stream on church I had a a a
stream a couple years ago where I was
like Rollo ruined church for me because
once I saw this like because I always
felt like there was something like weird
about church and I couldn't put my like
I couldn't describe like what and it
really bothered me right because like
you know I think I think religion's
great like I believe in God I pray you
know but
there was just something weird about it
and I seriously I couldn't figure out
what but I would go I remember sitting
in Catholic school and they would have
these Chastity speakers come in and I've
always been me like I've always had
strong opinions about whatever just like
I'm just the person that gives their
opinion and they would have these
Chastity speakers and it would always be
the same thing like the the guy with the
ran through chick and they would come
and so they can't tell me they don't
preach this because y'all literally and
these were Christians too they weren't
even Catholic well this there some of
them were Christians that came so you
guys cannot say oh we don't preach this
no no I was in high school you guys
literally preached this to me so I will
not none of this and they'll talk about
these girls will come in and say oh I
did all this stuff whatever and now like
I found this husband I found God and I'm
like well this only worked because she
was hot one of the girls that came was
literally an ax America's Next Top Model
that is not gonna work for your average
chick all right this works for the hot
chick and what the real message should
be is hey you have this this has been
waiting for you if you make these
choices but if you [__] around too much
there ain't [__] at the end of this
tunnel I think that's a little bit more
on unless you're really hot you'll
probably get away with it hot people
just have privilege like life is life
you know and and so that's what it's
just like not honest and I can't even
have and the the Christian guys will
clip me and like they'll um like there's
this one guy that said in the title that
I I rejected Christianity or something
and I'm like isn't that lying like you
got like and I'm like you're not having
this conversation in good faith if
that's what you're putting in this
costume Channel and they're literally
lying about you yes in the title that's
not what I said I said like this is
something I disagree with in the church
and I don't I don't remember word for
word what the title is so what they'll
do is they'll say oh it was something
like that and so I was just like how are
we supposed to have a conversation in
good faith and my issue with the like
Christianity is I'm like they preach
like two women and they never talk about
the men's issues though there's a
there's a corn and and I I don't
remember someone told me this so this
wasn't me but there's like a corn
addiction group but there's no social
media addiction group and there's all
these women that lead the relationships
and then I see pastors coming on and
saying oh well if your husband's not
leading you to God then how are you
supposed to follow him and I'm like your
submission is not supposed to be
dependent on your husband's Behavior
just like his provisioning or whatever
isn't supposed to be dependent on on
your behavior like you can't and and so
that's what I was realized I'm like
they're all just like there's a lot of
simps in the church that just lie to us
and it pisses me off because you're
telling us like you're selling women
this dream that's not true and then I'll
see these like I was in church right I
was in this Christian church for a while
and I would see like this 25 year old
chick who is a virgin She's Fit she's
feminine I'm like why is she not like
married this is the ideal right and I'm
thinking like there's no men in the
church there's like they're all like I
know and the stats will say it's 50 50
50 but if you look under a certain age
and the singles groups like there were
singles like Ministry like setting
people up at this church and it was like
90 women that were signing up to this
and they also don't talk about how the
women are worse in the church why are
guys saying that why are guys saying
that it's a red flag if if there's God
first in your dating app why even and
I'm Catholic all right but like why do
we have such a bad reputation why do and
the churches will will come in and it
irritates me because they're not honest
like you're coming in and you're saying
oh well it's just the churches you go
not all churches are like that but
you're not addressing the actual problem
and that's what you're it just you're I
just find it annoying it's like and so
I'm not trying to take away from church
of course I think church is a great
thing I think marriage is a great thing
but it happened how can we how can we
fix it if we can't even identify it's a
problem and you're selling women this
bill of goods that at 28 that any guy
that she's going to be attracted to is
going to wait I'm sorry it's just you
that's ship sailed at 22 when or what
nowadays it's like 15. you feel like the
church is having a part to play in this
idea of having women who had a
lascivious past and now they're coming
back to the church but here's the thing
because you came back to us in repayment
for you coming back to us we're going
we've got a myriad of simps that you can
choose from and then you can end up
marrying one of these dudes yes and the
women and the church is telling these
men specifically to have so little
experience with women that they go for
this idea and then now it becomes almost
like a transaction we are getting women
back from only fans and then we're
giving them to these simp men who have
no experience with women and then the
two of them are accepting this or this
Arrangement which will inevitably end in
divorce because these women are not
going to want these men and they lead
the relate like I see it like women the
women lead the relationships yes and
like they Don't Preach like about like I
could not when I saw this clip and maybe
there was more context of this preacher
saying your submission to your husband
like is like what if he's not leading
you to God and I'm like well how would
she know like she's supposed to follow
his lead and where is the question like
why would you pick someone that's not
leading you to God and plus it's like
women we change our minds every God damn
day sorry gosh damn day and um like so
you don't even know and so maybe one day
you think he's leading you to God one
day you think he's not like that's not
supposed to be the choice the choice is
hey you married him you follow his lead
and you pray like my my
um
like you know I know people in my family
that didn't leave their husbands for
like adultery because they believed he
would go to hell if they left him that
was the level of like of of belief they
had to work it out well yeah well and
faith and that's the thing like where
they really believed what they said and
that's why like I think the men go to
church and they're just like well the
quality of women here is worse the
pastor's gaslighting me because he's
telling me the quality of women isn't
worse and yeah so I'm not and I I I'd
like to say I like church I'm for church
church good religion it's all good yes
but how are we supposed to have good
faith conversations if these guys are
pandering to women constantly yeah
that's was that was a really interesting
topic that I heard you talk about I I
was because I hadn't thought about it
like that but I have seen something
similar where it's like one of the
problems is
um what's very controversial in red pill
is this idea that men should have some
experience with women and the church
does not encourage that and when that
happens you end up in a situation like
with Stephen Crowder I think Stephen
Crowder is a great content creator I
think Steve Crowder has some really
interesting ideas but Stephen Crowder
does not know more about women than me
and I know he doesn't know more about
women than me because he didn't get a
[__] prenup in the state of Texas so
whatever he wants to say about how this
was the first person he was with and he
married her and God forbid if this
happens to Ben Shapiro because if it
happens they're gonna the world is going
to come down on it because he told all
of us you need to marry the first woman
that you you need to marry the first
woman that you sleep with and by the way
there's nothing wrong with him saying
that that's totally fine the problem is
when you tell the rest of us who
actually wanted experience with women to
to uh that we were wrong for what we're
doing we're not making those same
mistakes and we are better at picking up
those red flags that the church you're
saying that the church has
well and the issue issue too is they
don't really
reaction like the men sleeping with a
bunch of women I I think it's a reaction
to the way women are because they don't
want to get bamboozled how are they how
are you supposed to know because let's
be honest like women will like what
what's the girl's body the girls are
gonna lie for days so how is a guy
supposed to know if she's like an actual
genuine girl or like a girl that's like
been ran through and is just like Po you
know the born-again stuff without having
experience with women and it's not like
like so I was thinking about it I'm like
the women don't want to get married
young yeah so like because the guys want
to marry the women young as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible